السياحه الفضائيه مفهوم تجاري يفتح افاق
الفضاء امام السياح والزوار ولكن بتكلفه
ليست بالقليله سعر تذكره للذهاب الى
الفضاء يبلغ 55 مليون دولار او ما يعادل
سته ملايين الف دولار في اليوم الواحد
تتضمن التدريب وتخطيط المهمه والدعم الطبي
والبقاء ثمانيه ايام على متن محطه الفضاء
الدوليه تكلفه الطعام الخاص في الفضاء الف
دولار في اليوم الواحد اكياس النوم
والملابس ومنتجات النظافه
1500 دولار في اليوم الواحد تكلفه توصيل
المعدات الى المحطه الفضائيه مقدما 20,000
دولار للكيلو جرام مع نفس الرسوم للتخلص
منها بعد ذلك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات